>> John: REMARKABLE TURN OF
EVENTS, THANKS.
DEMOCRATS IN CONGRESS ARE
DEMANDING ATTORNEY GENERAL
WILLIAM BARR DELIVER THE MUELLER
REPORT BY APRIL 2ND BUT IT WILL
BE WEEKS, NOT DAYS BEFORE HE
COMES UP WITH A VERSION THAT CAN
BE MADE PUBLIC.
WHILE FIGHTING OVER WHAT IS IN
THAT VERSION WILL CONTINUE,
PRESIDENT TRUMP HAS A THEORY ON
WHERE THE INVESTIGATION BEGAN,
CORRESPONDED KEVIN CORKE REPORTS
FROM THE WHITE HOUSE.
>> President Trump: THIS
SHOULD NEVER HAPPEN TO A
PRESIDENT AGAIN, WE CAN'T ALLOW
THAT.
[REPORTER QUESTIONING]
I DON'T WANT TO SAY THAT BUT I
THINK YOU KNOW THE ANSWER.
>> John: AN ASTONISHING THEORY
ON CAPITOL HILL, THE GENESIS OF
THE RUSH INVESTIGATION AND
SUBSEQUENT MUELLER PROBE MAY
HAVE BEEN THE WORK OF THE OBAMA
WHITE HOUSE.
>> President Trump: I THINK IT
WAS VERY HIGH UP, I THINK WHAT
HAPPENED WAS A DISGRACE, I DON'T
THINK OUR COUNTRY SHOULD ALLOW
THIS EFFORT TO HAPPEN AGAIN.
>> John: THE PRESIDENT'S
CONCERN MIRRORS THAT OF WHAT
HAPPENED IN CONGRESS, MANY OF
WHOM BELIEVE THE BASIS OF THE
INVESTIGATION DESERVES A MUCH
CLOSER LOOK AND PERHAPS ITS OWN
SPECIAL COUNSEL.
REPUBLICANS WANT TO GET TO THE
BOTTOM OF HOW THINGS BEGAN,
DEMOCRATS SAY THEY WANT TO MORE
CLOSELY INSPECT THE PROBES
FINISHED PRODUCT AND THEY WANTED
BY THEIR APRIL 2ND DEADLINE OR
ELSE.
>> WE HAVE SUBPOENA POWER AND I
DON'T SEE ANYTHING IN THE
SPECIAL COUNSEL'S REGULATIONS
THAT WOULD PROHIBIT
ATTORNEY GENERAL FROM RELEASING
IT.
>> 84 PAGE SUMMARY THAT MAY BE
COLORED BY THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL'S PERSONAL
VIEWS IS NOT ADEQUATE.
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE NEED TO SEE
THE WHOLE REPORT.
>> John: SOURCES TELL FOX NEWS
SAY THE ATTORNEY GENERAL
BELIEVES IT WILL TAKE WEEKS TO
GET A VERSION OF THE REPORT TO
CAPITOL HILL.
WHILE ADAM SCHIFF AND FELLOW
DEMOCRATS WANT TO SEE FULL
REPORT, REPUBLICANS WANT HIM TO
RESIGN FROM HIS POST ON THE
HOUSE INTELLIGENCE COMMITTEE IN
PART BECAUSE OF REPEATED CLAIMS
THAT EVIDENCE OF COLLUSION WITH
THE RUSSIANS WAS IN PLAIN SIGHT
AND THAT ACCORDING TO THE
SPECIAL COUNSEL TURNED OUT TO BE
FALSE.
>> I THINK ADAM SCHIFF SHOULD
STEP DOWN AS THE CHAIRMAN OF THE
HOUSE INTELLIGENCE COMMITTEE, HE
MENTIONED THERE WAS CREDIBLE
EVIDENCE HE HAD SEEN AND
VERIFIED AND AFTER A TWO YEAR
LENGTHY INVESTIGATION BY A VERY
RESPECTED PROSECUTOR, WE HAVE NO
EVIDENCE OF COLLUSION.
>> John: JOHN GREENE IS NOT
ALONE IN HIS CALLS FOR ADAM
SCHIFF TO RESIGN, THE CALIFORNIA
CONGRESSMAN COULD BE ON THE WAY
OUT, SHOULD BE ON THE WAY OUT
SAYS KEVIN McCARTHY.
HE WANTS THEM TO GIVE UP THE
CHAIRMANSHIP, SO DOES
KELLYANNE CONWAY THE SENIOR
ADVISOR TO THE PRESIDENT IN THE
WHITE HOUSE.
HE'S NOT GIVING UP THE POST